movement watches was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank classic design quality construction
and styled minimalism movement watches
that's what this episode is brought to
you by get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement dot-com slashing dress that's
MV M t.com / congrats this episode is
all - also brought to you by square cash
which is the best money transferring app
there is everyone is switching to the
cash app because it's the best way to
pay people back most payments can be
deposited to your bank and seconds if
you use the other apps to pay people
then you're just you're living in the
dark ages
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now hey guys what's up
it's episode 31 and when I say hey guys
what's up my dog gets all perky come
here dude
[Music]
congratulations episode 31 in Mashhad
back from Salt Lake City Utah and it was
a blast
I love Salt Lake City I like Salt Lake
City I don't know if it's ad love Salt
Lake City but I like Salt Lake City
because well I've only been in the
summer really but also I've never been
in January and people are like oh but
it's beautiful you go because it's
snowing and yeah but it's too cold
naturally so let's just go in the summer
and that's it
but it was so so hot and then I got back
to LA and it was way cooler so it was
cool I did six shows there and it's a
different it's a different way you hold
out actually before I even [ __ ] start
this [ __ ] go to Chris D'Elia calm and
look at my toward
you can go to you know I got New
Brunswick New Jersey coming up I got
Tempe and Phoenix and I got some
Australia dates Charlotte North Carolina
and there's merch there too chris d'elia
calm you can get all the congratulations
merchandise and so anyway also watch man
on fire and rate and review this [ __ ]
thing please because I'm I'm actually I
Teeter on you know III like doing it but
then I Teeter on like well if nobody's
gonna be it's not gonna be growing I'm
gonna stop you know it's like in a good
business when they're like yeah business
has to grow otherwise it's dead that's
what this is this is a business you
understand besides the fact that it's a
cult so I was in what do you call a Salt
Lake City which is cool
it's you know people are like oh there's
so many Mormons is it is it weird
everyone is like is it was it weird to
do your show there when with so many
Mormons do they get it and it's like
yeah dude they get it cuz you know why
they're people but I don't you know
Taylor my act to [ __ ] in certain
religion or whatever and honestly if
they are offended I want them to be
offended because [ __ ] it you know but I
did six shows there and the only the
only jokes that they got a little bit
sensitive about was when I started
talking [ __ ] about animals my little
doggies and but yeah it's weird it's a
different pace of life out there I mean
everybody's so nice it's a little bit
like the step or what is it the stepford
blows that movie with the Nicole Kim and
they remade separate wise yeah where
they're like they seem like a little too
nice and it's a little creepy but that's
probably only because the rest of the
world is [ __ ] dicks but they're so
nice and even if they're not Mormon
they're also like like close to Mormons
so like there's just a way of living
there is like so nice and [ __ ] I had
people come up to me that were just like
so friendly but one time I was eating at
this place in this was like two two days
ago
I was eating at this place in in Salt
Lake City and I was with my opener Mike
and this guy comes in and I saw him like
see me and you know you get really good
at like when somebody knows who you are
and even though they're trying to play
it off you get really good at like
noticing that they that they did but so
I saw this guy do that and he ordered
his food and then all of a sudden he's
right there as I'm sitting he's face was
so close to my face and he put his hands
on his knees here's a real tall drink of
water so that's why he [ __ ] did that
and he looked he was like his face was
right near my face and he goes like this
hey Chris and I and it turned around and
I was like yeah oh what's up man and I
like leaned away a little bit I don't
know what do some people talk so close
and it's like naturally move back
b-before dude I can hear you honestly I
can hear you if you're [ __ ] 25 feet
away so there's no reason to be there's
no reason to be touching my cheek with
your nose so he was talking and he was
like hey man I just want to let you know
I'm your I'm a really big fan and i
watch your standup even though my
parents won't let me watch it with them
now that story seems fine however the
guy had a beard so it's not fine because
v old enough to grow beard and don't say
I can't my parents won't allow me to
watch whatever the rest of the sentence
is my parents won't allow me to watch
doesn't matter don't say those words in
any sentence because you got a beard you
tall drink of water
it means you passed puberty then don't
say my parents won't allow me to watch
Hey I'll stop right there you too old
I'll start right there you 25 if your
parents won't let you watch you stand up
with him then I think he was being
really sweet I think what he meant to
say was my parents won't watch it with
me but what said was my parents later
many hey you too all for that okay
are you your parents Pat no oh cool man
just live your life but it was really
really weird and he was he was nervous
and his hands were shaking when he was
talking so I felt like it was really
sweet you know but also may duct-tape
your parents in a chair and make them
watch it you know duct tape your parents
in the chair and make them watch my
comedy that's my [ __ ] thing right
there duct tape your parents hey here's
the deal if your parents are real
religious duct tape your parents to
chair to a chair and make him watch em
comedy all right um so anyway I did my
shows there and they were really good
actually the last time I was out
wiseguys the club is awesome the last
time I was at wiseguys it was it was
good and this time it was great I don't
know what it was but the crowds were
like way better and I don't know if they
were more excited I hadn't been there in
a year but loved it and so that's it I
got coffee people were like you got to
try this coffee place to try the coffee
place wasn't good got pissed off all
good all good dude all good if you know
all I want is good good that's why I end
up going to [ __ ] shitty ass Starbucks
because I know what I'm gonna get by the
way I just came from the coffee the
coffee shop right now and this guy said
and this crazy guy there's all dude I
don't know why I know I've talked about
this bro I don't know why people are I
don't know at what point it's like
people are the most there how come crazy
people are the most crazy like I never
noticed somebody III granted it's more
than it's noticeable more noticeable
when somebody's the most crazy but you
never like you never see somebody that's
like [ __ ] man was that a spider and
you're like there's no spider there
you're like I should've thought of so
spider sorry you never see somebody
who's that who's that crazy it's always
somebody that's like well you know it's
the government it's the governor
in me in a [ __ ] Macy's with like no
shirt on like at what point usually that
guy went to [ __ ] zero to a hundred
real quick that's what the Drake song is
about a guy [ __ ] snapping and
becoming crazy um no but uh and he said
what did he say I [ __ ] walked out the
coffee shop and he said I thought his
talk to me until I realized it wasn't
talking to me because he said something
like oh oh oh he said the bottom line is
first of all if anybody's talking about
the bottom line you're a little bit more
crazy than somebody who doesn't talk
about the bottom line because that's
[ __ ] insane to be like well the
bottom line is the bottom line is you
know people say the bottom line is about
a lot [ __ ] anything about sports well
look the bottom line is you know he
can't [ __ ] throw faster than 90 miles
an hour the bottom line is he's not
scoring touchdowns the bottom line is
he's not scoring goals so that's so you
know you gotta take him out that's that
that's the bottom line
weed gets down to brass tacks when it
gets down to brass tacks he's not
throwing you know what all said and done
that's like [ __ ] some [ __ ] but it's
all said and done he's not making
baskets the bottom line is how about
Vint what was it Vin Scully was that the
guy baseball yeah who's the only [ __ ]
baseball announcer that there's just one
of them left like there's always there's
always two guys because it's like when
when there was one guy that was like so
old-timey they'd have like one guy
calling the [ __ ] and then and then every
team was like hey what are we doin let's
have two guys and then one guy was like
the color commentator and then the other
guy was like the guy who like knew all
the stats and [ __ ] and but Vin Scully
was like the last remaining guy that was
just one guy did he die he's still up
but he retired right side or a tire dude
he would [ __ ] Vin Scully was it was
the LA Dodgers announcer and he was the
only he was the guy that would like just
talk and non-stop talk he would non-stop
talk about these players and he would be
like
we no other guy that would be like yeah
you're right and also yada yada but he
would be like Kirk Gibson steps too bad
Kirk having is struggling struggling
this year but really coming into his own
when it comes playoff season Kirk family
originated from Italy a little bit like
would talk about the ship because
because he had to fill a space he would
talk about things that had nothing to do
with baseball but they held him on
because it was like royalty it'd be like
Kirk Gibson the last time he didn't have
his mustache was wet he was 14 his
mother said in a magazine they
interviewed his mama and you were like
he and then he would get to at relaf so
hard that they would start throwing
pitches and [ __ ] and baseball action
would be happening and he would be like
so that's why Kirk Gibson Shops at IKEA
it goes to Circuit City swigging abyss
and you'd be like dude you're missing
out the [ __ ] butt on the basket on
the baseball it would really happen he'd
be like Jah doll rude steps up against
what's the [ __ ] Venezuela who's that
guy
verdad though Venezuela
first of all the name is the most Latino
name of all time
Fernando Venezuela Venezuela it's whele
valid suela Valenzuela Fernando
Valenzuela who's sub4sub reason pitchers
are the only people in baseball that
could be fat for some reason every
baseball player is either Sibiu E or
jacked
except for pitchers pitchers are the
only position in baseball where you
could be a fat slob the ugliest players
in baseball if you look like now if
you're a first baseman
your legs are trunks if you're a
shortstop you're fast and sinewy if
you're even if you're a designated
hitter you've got strong shoulders but
somehow if you're a pitcher from the
eighties
you look like a couch potato Fernando
Valenzuela pitching to john olerude John
Rhodes our base percentage is 425 I mean
who is that pitcher they're pulling up
pitchers mom I mean what's that gonna
have man how come you can be I don't
understand how you can be so not looking
like a sports guy but still be a pitcher
but that's what he would do he would be
he would talk about anything other than
baseball and then when the action would
happen to be too late and he just likes
I'd [ __ ] sneak in it he'd be by the
way foreign a Novelis was not fat I mean
it's just like so dumb that I'm saying
it but he just doesn't look like a
[ __ ] studly [ __ ] but he would be
like Jose Canseco steps up to the bat
for Fernando Valenzuela Fernando throat
Fernando from a small town in where's he
from Ecuador and moved over to Los
Angeles what his parents finally
scrounge up enough money to get over and
what he did
him and eight other family members sat
in a one-bedroom apartment for years
until triple-a came calling long fly
ball deep to set her head ease out
that's gonna be like hey man up I'm
trying to watch [ __ ] baseball
technical difficulties technical [ __ ]
difficulties dude
this [ __ ] thing's falling but hey
producer get over here do it and you
know what's coming one fire them dude
there we go there we go
chintzy [ __ ] things here chintzy
[ __ ] things sorry for the [ __ ]
sorry so sorry for the sound [ __ ] and
also if you're visually watching you
might see the microphone fall down swig
abyss so yeah
Fernando Valenzuela it so Latino
Fernando Valenzuela hit so Latino so
anyway um that was well I don't I have
literally have no idea what I was
talking about until I got to with how I
got to [ __ ] Vin Scully
by the way Vin Scully you note I mean
[ __ ] Aryan that those announcers are
[ __ ] amazing though
who's the one [ __ ] hey [ __ ] dick
fight oh is that that [ __ ] guy
dick vital Hey hey dick fight tell every
time I would see dick fight al even
though when I was eight I'd be like hey
man calm the [ __ ] down
[ __ ] relax
imagine have a Thanksgiving dinner with
that [ __ ] guy like this before
put it in your [ __ ] mouths did I am
thankful for volume without volume
you'd be like dick Veidt tells it be
like who wants to go first I'll be like
I'll go first
I'd be like oh I'm thankful for the
family mr. Veidt al would be like I'm
thank you for the fit thank you for the
family I'm really happy that even though
everyone's busy schedule we can all get
together and it's great and I really
appreciate it
why don't you go and then his dick fight
Al's dad's like well I'm just happy I'm
happy you know that uh I'm able to be
employed you know times are tough yadda
yadda and then like a [ __ ] that why
don't you go and dig fight our sisters
like I'm just
happy you know because people are
treating me really cool at school and it
was tough to get situated in everything
but now I really seem to be coming into
my own
and then 22 year old dick fight I was
like okay go ahead dick and they were
like the way we could all come together
and eat stuffing it dick vital dude
Sutekh I mean Italian dick vital and Vin
Scully if they had a kid it would be
like [ __ ] you know what they had a
kid and it was Mario and Luigi from
[ __ ] wait were those were they yeah
they were right from me Nene Mooney me
me putting ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
thinking I feel like when super mario
brothers when they made that [ __ ]
song that just feels like the [ __ ] no
deist song you know what I mean like
it's like I feel like they were like you
know how like some songs are like
[ __ ] I don't know it's like like like
ok like [ __ ] tick pop goes the
weasel' Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing
Thing they didn't think they we zap how
because we think the name Tang Tang Tang
Tang there that's it that's the [ __ ]
thing and I goes I don't think they
think that that thing and then over
again over and over again but some rare
brothers this [ __ ] did notes just
never stop dude it's like anything think
the thing ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding anything think anything
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off when's it come around
I think that they think think think
think think think think think that they
think that they think think think
ding ding ding ding then think what what
are you turning it into it's like you
could literally turn into a little yacht
a little yachty song and it would just
[ __ ] I think they think they think
that they think that they think think
think think think think think think like
how [ __ ] insane they were just like
do just keep going man just keep [ __ ]
making notes who gives a [ __ ] man
this is the weirdest game ever it
doesn't matter
they're jumping on lizards poop it
they're jumping on Turtles kind of and
then they transport into [ __ ] green
tubes and then go underground do me do
me do me do me do me do me
and then even that one you think it just
gonna be do me do me do me and you're
like okay this one's a little bitter to
me do me do me
[Music]
[ __ ] you doing and I get that part took
it to mean doing some [ __ ] leader
came in and like mr. Mario Brothers came
in and was like I needed to be busier
and they were like dude he's such a
[ __ ] dick dude the way he comes in
he's obviously dealing with the divorce
and it [ __ ] sucks that he comes in
and tells us what to do why don't we
just [ __ ] give him all the notes well
dude we have to get on me talking to me
to me and talking and then we could just
go lower don't be too mean to me don't
get too mean to me kappa dude check this
out I came up with this last night this
guy's being such a [ __ ] dick dude
here we [ __ ] go check this out we're
gonna give him this he's gonna kill us
man way to get here what I got for stage
1 think think think think think think
think think dude
hey sorry for being so annoying but also
you know what the number one no deist
song is this is the number one no Deus
song oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah the I don't
know try to do this acapella you know
how every song you can do acapella like
like every song you can do acapella like
you can be like
Oh May I'm gonna know yeah mm-hmm like
there's Google dolls right or he could
be like what's his song [ __ ] he
literally can't think of a song what's a
Billy Joel song [ __ ] yeah no it's a
[ __ ] we didn't start the fire this is
the no da song of all time
[ __ ] right here I'm gonna play the
beginning of it just the beginning of it
oh of course
an ad hey YouTube get it together dude
nope nope not know Peter Lorre until it
starts but um this is the no Dias song
you can't [ __ ] do it acapella try to
do it
our capella my producer and I used to
talk about this a lot okay when it
starts oh it [ __ ] doesn't even start
at the beginning god damn it
if you gotta upload the [ __ ] song
just upload it from the beginning dude I
mean you know how the fit the p IM p
song starts diddly new thing thing thing
thing thing you can't do it you can't do
it acapella ding-ding-ding you can't do
it and then it goes to you think think
think think they think thing of course I
get it now my question is and what I've
noticed now is how come this music video
on YouTube has 224 million views that's
[ __ ] insane dude the first [ __ ]
comment is I don't like the censoring of
these songs hey man
bye yet oh it's 49 cents on iTunes get a
Spotify I don't like the censoring
imagine [ __ ] watching the video and
then being like dude I don't like the
censoring on this [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
being like got a comment it maybe this
is it I'm just gonna
anyway what was I talking about I was
talking about dick fight ow
and before that I was talking about side
retired rue de dude what's his name add
Vin Scully and dick fight al if Vin
Scully [ __ ] came up with a Vin Scully
would say side retired it would have 45
syllables in it every time side retired
and that's it and he's out now we'll be
back after these messages
side retired laughs who do the Japanese
mmm-hmm that's what the guy was saying
when I walked out the coffee shop he was
saying the bottom line is we'll see how
long it takes for me to to focus the
bottom line is we'll see how long it
takes for me to take a [ __ ] out or
something whatever was and I was like oh
Jesus he was crazy
and he was talking to no one uh-huh
anyway hey dogs come here have you heard
of movement watches if you haven't you
live under a rock it spelled em VMT
movement watches was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank the watchmakers goal is to change
the way consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices over a
million watches sold to customers in 160
plus countries around the world the
doing the job so do yours I got one it's
awesome it's gold it's like sleek it's
like minimal style so it looks like I
know what I'm doing it's very cool it's
cooler than I am most watches start at
just $95
at the department store you looking at
400 to 500 bucks get out of here have
this sent to you movement figured out
selling online that they were able to
cut the middleman out and retail markup
providing the best possible price get
50% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Congrats I've been getting compliments
ever since I put mine on no joke for
real now is the time to step up your
watch game go to MVM t.com slash
Congrats join the movement blink kissed
you know about these guys I like to know
stuff so I don't sound stupid now let me
tell you something I am stupid and I
like reading books but I often don't
have a lot of spare time introducing the
blinkin app over 2,000 of the
best-selling non-fiction books
transformed into powerful packs you can
read or listen to in just 15 minutes
it's great it's like you know it it gets
you all the info that you need so you
don't seem like niddy yet like me but
you can feast your mind on the key ideas
from the top best-selling non-fiction
books like how to stop worrying and
start living emotional intelligence and
the 80/20 principle now if you don't
even know what those books are don't be
stupid
get this if you're just reading you'll
get through maybe but I like one book a
week but with the blink estab you can
get through you can get the key insights
from two or three books on your way home
Forbes BuzzFeed the New York Times and
Lifehacker are all talking about blinka
it's just these guys are great alright
right now blink East has a special offer
just for our audience that's the babies
go to blink it's calm / Congrats right
now to start your free trial or get
three months off your yearly plan when
you join today that's blinking spelled
bli NK ist blink is calm / congrats to
start your free trial or get three
months off your yearly plan blink is
calm / Congrats I don't know what it is
about by the way reading like
I just become a [ __ ] idiot when I
start reading and I think it's because
I'm like I try to I try to read it and
then as halfway through the page I'm
just like [ __ ] I want chocolate and then
I started thinking about chocolate for
like a split second but I've read two
sentences since then and then I go back
and I'm like oh [ __ ] who's who's this
that they're talking about now they
introduce someone else will I [ __ ]
thought about chocolate and I gotta go
back three lines and then it's over it's
over I go back three lines that I'm like
I might as well just quit here you know
what [ __ ] it I'm just gonna be dumb
literally every [ __ ] thing I read
halfway through I'll be like oh I'm so
[ __ ] I'm just gonna choose to be dumb
[Music]
i-i-i-i well [ __ ] man
I don't know I've been tracking like my
f oh my calories and my workouts and
stuff it's been good man
I've been going [ __ ] hard I burned
like 640 calories the other day running
up and down my stairs and [ __ ] I get my
Irish buddy to do it with me and he's
always like or it's an unreal workout
huh I'm like yeah man uh how's your
chest feel my feels unreal I don't know
I don't know but um oh wait I had a
[ __ ] thing I wanted to talk about and
I don't remember it oh oh dude I don't
know how I feel about this this is this
is and I know people are gonna say
they're so it's beautiful and I know I'm
gonna get [ __ ] for this maybe although
I'm not that important so maybe not but
like these these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
these these [ __ ] setup pregnancy
photos like these set up pregnancy
photos we're like there's so much
[ __ ]
like you're on a beach and you've got
like a [ __ ] halo around your head and
like I'd like a beautiful like sheer
cape and you're holding your stomach and
like hey and I mean this and I'm gonna
say this be happy that you pregnant mm
happy pregnant
keep to yourself and also you can take a
picture of you being pregnant but what
are you in a venture a [ __ ] are you
standing on a rock for and it's always
the picture it's always of them it's
always of the woman like one arm under
the belly one arm on top of the belly
belly and and she's like doing the most
caring astray sub all-time with her eyes
like either looking at the belly or like
hold or like closing her eyes just
really trying to meditate on that embryo
and she's always got like a [ __ ] like
a like a like IV around her [ __ ] head
hey hey I got a question for you what
about having another human being inside
you makes you want to put IV around your
head you're the Statue of David by the
way why did the Statue of David have the
littlest [ __ ] you know that whoever made
it was a Michelangelo we did that one
he had the littlest [ __ ] of all time
because he only painted people with
little [ __ ] that's a very weird fetish
hey Michelangelo paint someone with a
fat [ __ ] why wouldn't you dude if I was
a sculpture I would if I was a sculptor
not if I was a sculpture but if I was a
sculptor and somebody's like dude I want
a [ __ ] statue of a man who's naked is
[ __ ] and I'd be like all right cool I'd
make the [ __ ] so so so veiny and big
because and then when he would be like
and then because here's why because then
if somebody was like the owner of the
guy who commissioned me they'd be like
hey why is his [ __ ] so big I'd be like
what do you mean that's regular-sized
BAM got you now I know you have a small
[ __ ] guy who [ __ ] Commission to me so
they wouldn't do that so I would
basically make paintings and statues of
guys with huge [ __ ] and nobodies would
be saying [ __ ] because it'd be too
insecure to be like why is his [ __ ] so
big cuz then I'd [ __ ] slam him and
I'd be like that's a regular-sized [ __ ]
then you know I got a big [ __ ] and you
got a small [ __ ]
he's your [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] there's your
[ __ ] lit dude
David's [ __ ] was a [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
care David's [ __ ] was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
does he [ __ ] stroke it or does he uh
you know Pat it that's how the statute
David jerks off he Pat's it like a [ __ ]
now going to hell yeah does it matter
no it's not how Statue of David sabay
sick to david most regular name well who
is that anyway David Oh David and
Goliath oh oh okay so David was the
small one right so that's why his [ __ ]
was small so not only was David the
small one his [ __ ] was small so he was
small and his [ __ ] was even smaller get
out of here do it I would have made
David smaller and his [ __ ] would be
dragging on the ground
dragging it would be so like nice and
like folded on the ground with all like
the [ __ ] skin and I would have been
me I would have made it like extra long
and trailing behind him and then people
would have been like why would people be
like why would um why would you make his
[ __ ] so big and I would be like you guys
have small [ __ ] dude I'm gonna go paint
a [ __ ] ceiling and get [ __ ] oil
paint dripping in my eyes and then die
from it um yeah David and Goliath
Goliath I want to see that guy's [ __ ]
you know what I would have done I would
have made the Sistine Chapel and I would
have [ __ ] painted it on the ceiling
and I would have had the [ __ ] [ __ ]
coming down like I would have had the
[ __ ] like I would have sculpted the
cops [ __ ] coming down off of the
ceiling that's what I would do
it's a blasphemous but that's what I
would do and then people would be like
whoa what's hanging down up there and
I'd be like oh the [ __ ]
where's my money maybe like we should
probably take the [ __ ] off and I'd be
like you gotta hire someone to take the
carcass off I already did my work and
that would have been like I'll take the
[ __ ] off and I'll be like and then I
would have got up there and I've been
like oh they're too hard to take off and
it would have looked like I was jerking
him off and I do you do your [ __ ]
self [ __ ] and I would have walked
out with paint all over my face I can't
take it off I'm trying to take it off
over and over again who's like I'm
taking it off [ __ ] off [ __ ] I'm out
of here
[ __ ] Italy that's what I would have done
see ya and then I would have walked by
David I would have been like it's got a
small [ __ ] it's like yours [ __ ] out of
here and I would have walked by with my
toga and IV by the way but pregnancy
photos do it you know like get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] who you
getting pregnant for we get him pregnant
for who the [ __ ] you getting pregnant
for you
you gave pregnant for your family you
getting pregnant for [ __ ] onlookers
in Malibu we get pregnant for the people
in Instagram bye
turn around it's free [ __ ] but change it
I hit you with the [ __ ] combo right
there do it I hit you with the [ __ ]
illest congratulations combo right there
that it's [ __ ] unreal do you
understand me dude
you've taken pregnancy photos for who
dude what are you doing who are you
doing it for you're doing it for your
Instagram followers no I forget what
combo hit you with but here comes a new
one
change it turn round you're doing it for
who [ __ ] you CUDA I [ __ ] smashed
you with a congratulations combo first
one was a little better but you got to
get hit with some combos dude like the
end of the [ __ ] mcgregor fight you
exhausted because I'm hitting you with
combos and yeah so I don't know dude but
like here's the deal
everyone thinks they're [ __ ] Beyonce
that's what it is nah you just you just
someone every girl thinks they're
Beyonce every guy thinks he's the rock
secretly
yet change it Ioan important you got a
day job so don't be taking pictures like
the number-one R&B singer and stop with
the [ __ ] caring ass [ __ ] I'm
holding my belly this is life this is
how life forms yeah we know man
we took a [ __ ] science class don't
give me that face I want a present
pregnancy photo where the chick is
[ __ ] posing like she be on WWF or WCW
we're like she's like doing a screaming
face like yeah and her arms are out and
she's like looking at the camera and
they're [ __ ] fat bellies just hanging
over that's the [ __ ] pregnancy photo
I want it's so [ __ ] crazy how
important everybody thinks they are all
because of Instagram and social media
bye
no but it's all good but by nobody you
have a lot of followers and you want to
post a picture that's cool
but step back a few spaces and now hold
on a second thunk okay turn round so the
door can hitch on the ass on the way out
of gunk the gunk the baby the gunk slam
the baby falls out you uterus the gunk
sorry should have taken a few steps
forward but good dunk the door hit yes
and made you baby fall out of uterus and
slide across the [ __ ] linoleum floor
like air hockey you baby
across the [ __ ] linoleum floor like
air hockey don't worry it'll come back
cuz the umbilical cord you person
it's gross this is science this is not
beautiful this is science I love when
people pretend that [ __ ] is so beautiful
just because it's natural hey you know
what else is natural me shittin do ever
look at my [ __ ] and be like oh it's
beautiful
no cuz you know why it's just a burrito
bowl transformed into brown okay it's
some tofu and hot sauce oh it's
beautiful
oh really keep it and frame it keep it
and frame it put it above the fireplace
oh what's that that's gross that's my
[ __ ] it's beautiful its natural now am i
comparing a newborn to [ __ ] yes I am no
is that a problem yes it is
but is this a calmly parkus isn't it
it's not for don't win me that it's
wrong umm yeah oh say anyway pregnant
pregnancy photos change it I got out my
opener was trying to tell me because I
got a Fitbit I was a CUDA but that's not
true it's not coded I have a [ __ ]
Fitbit and you know why it's not good it
I have a Fitbit because a Fitbit is
[ __ ] functional your kuda if you just
[ __ ] get like a one of those [ __ ]
beaded bracelets for no reason you know
those [ __ ] or a puka shell necklace
ah kuda you saw it in a gift shop bought
it put around your neck you kuda alright
that's a great one leave that one dude
oh man you remember when I never mind um
all these quotes though man you know a
pregnancy photo would easily go with a
quote like a quote from Gandhi or some
[ __ ] or Mother Teresa or like [ __ ] TS
Eliot do you think TS Eliot gives a [ __ ]
about your
pregnancy photo on malabu no you know
why he's dead
also if he was alive wouldn't know yeah
also if he was alive he'd have about
6,000 Instagram followers snuffin know
why cuz she's smart but what do you call
it the people love a given quotes dude
people love quotes so important so
convoluted so stupid you know my
favorite quote is the most basic quote
of all time Tupac said it it was after
he [ __ ] got acquitted from rape and he
didn't do it and he came out of the
[ __ ] courthouse and everybody was
like Tupac what do you feel how do you
feel looking this and that and he says
they're trying to label me as a thug but
what they don't know is I'm businessman
and you could tell I'm businessman
because when you look for me you found
me in my place of business
that is the single best quote of all
time because he [ __ ] took it down to
their level look the reporters in the
eye and said some basic [ __ ] and that's
what he is
so basic so smart I love basic smart
quotes and [ __ ] no one's listening to
the other day the [ __ ] Elton John
song the [ __ ] is it the UM I was
listening to it the other day I'm arena
what the [ __ ] is it called a marina for
you know that song that's the girl's
name change it but when he says it when
it rains the rain falls around like new
[ __ ] but that's awesome hey when it
rains the rain falls down and washes
away I don't even know what the [ __ ] he
says I did it doesn't mention the rain
when it rains the rain falls down it's
basic it's a good you don't need to go
so [ __ ] far with it
so anyway what's up yeah and also
there's my quip here's something to chew
on many recent studies suggest that
having good oral health impacts your
overall health and it's true yet most of
us don't brush our teeth properly did
you know that
well you don't okay you can start
brushing better today introducing quip
the new company that's refreshing the
way people brush their teeth quip is an
electric toothbrush that packs premium
vibration and timer features into an
ultra slim design that's half the cost
of bulk your brushes it's actually
really cool I have it and it makes me
feel like I'm in the future because it's
it's it's it's kind of like like Apple
designed a toothbrush but without like a
big price tag it's it's it's it's an
expensive you have to see it and brush
it and brush with it yourself try to do
that try it okay you can even subscribe
to receive new brush heads on a dentist
recommended three month plan for just
five dollars including for each shipping
quip starts at just $25 right now go to
get clip comm / Congrats to get your
first refill pack with free and get your
first refill pack free with equip
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at get quip dot-com /
Congrats
g-e-t q UI p.com / congrats square cash
hi guys everyone is switching to the
cash app because it's the best way to
pay people back friends family
co-workers even kudus sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds here's how it works
babies download the square cash app link
your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a pay
and that's it dude snow more steps do
this square cache is better than the
other guys it's not a social network who
wants to have their payments listed in a
feed I don't know buddy
it's not Facebook its square cache I
don't want people knowing what I'm doing
with my money if I'm sending my money to
someone I want them to get it and I
don't want people to know I'm paying
them for sushi or whatever it is it's
the best way to do it I've got mine
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now I thought about a
funny thing where if a guy was on a date
with a girl I think this would be
awesome and I want somebody to do this
and report back to me a first or second
date when you haven't kissed the girl
yet Oh Chloe I'm so sweaty Hey good
thing it's 110 degrees in this in this
[ __ ] thing is awesome so if a guy had
went on a date I want somebody to do
this and then I want him to look yeah
this makes me laugh dude this is like
the old onion I'm so cool not as funny
but still when the guy if a guy like at
the end of dinner and he walks are done
or place and whatever and then he says
well I have a good night and he says
congratulations beautiful want a kiss I
think that would be s cringe-worthy and
I want to [ __ ] see a look on a girl's
face when a guy says that to her now I
won't ever do that no one ever see it
but if imagine the imagine the [ __ ]
ego on a guy who says you've won a kiss
oh dude it's awesome it's awesome to
think about a guy thinking so highly of
himself that that you he would say
you've won a kiss sweetheart and then
say sweetheart it's it's a condescending
to call a woman sweetheart I saw a guy
getting mad at a girl once in an in a
convenience store and he was like
sweetheart sweetheart sweetheart and I
was like yeah shitty mister
condescending had so many problems with
ladies when he was growing up
as mommy issues corn girl sweethearts
had his heart broken way too many times
uh so yeah but I'm chilling my babies
come here Bubba's come here come here
I'll grab my dogs come you guys hop up
come on Sammy
okay well you're being lazy as [ __ ] do
dogs sleep like 25 hours a day come here
remember when you guys [ __ ] on the floor
come here Sam come here Bubba
remember when you [ __ ] on the floor
buddy oh he's so [ __ ] precious man
you guys make up most of my act right
now that's weird I talked about you guys
way too much on my stand-up so I don't
really have much going on in my life you
guys say hi to the [ __ ] guys hi all
right cool no no knock it off Oh chill
man
thinking I think I beat you [ __ ] I'm in
pain babies worked out too hard pulled
muscles we're really gonna do something
about this heat man oh okay well why
don't we do this let's go 200 Jack could
do them I mean let me look at the
[ __ ] now what you calling most [ __ ]
up in scrimmage like I got a good one
right here hey guys here we go it's time
for the most [ __ ] up Instagram post to
the wheel here we go this is the one
that I want to talk about and I'm going
to say what here's a quote for [ __ ]
quotes morning Hart morning loves I
guess it means morning love so much
inner growth the pet anytime someone
talks about integral let me tell you
something right now if I know this if I
know anything it's this this is true
anyone talking about inner growth has
[ __ ] serious issues anyone talking
about their inner growth has let me tell
you something honestly cries hard every
other day
cries hard every other day morning love
so much inner growth the past few months
and I read this quote this morning and I
love it oh I can't wait to hear about
the quote that you loved so much inner
growth the past few months what does
that even mean by the way if you have
had inner growth the past few months
what does that mean you're happier what
does it mean you learn stuff about
yourself what does that mean does your
life change at all or do you just pretty
much do the same [ __ ] and maybe feel a
little bit better so much inner growth
oh really
can you teleport no then turn round
you're just saying [ __ ] you heard you're
you you're Rick you gir Dayton you
regurge Dayton what will happen to it
would it go here we go I have a [ __ ]
photos saved in my have saved photos in
my Instagram and it's and the folder
it's under is called uh Oh Oh morning
love so much integral at the past few
months and I read this quote this
morning and I love it quote you have the
power to say this is not how my story
will end oh that's the whole quote
that's the whole quote by the way you
don't ever need to start a quote with
you have the power to say because that's
what the [ __ ] quotation marks are for
not done with the sentence yet you
goddamn idiot now I'm done okay you have
the power to say is part of the quote
then let me tell you something you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] period this is not you
have the power to say this is not how
much Thoreau and hey are you seven or
a grown adult with a grown brain and
pubic hair because if you are then you
don't need to tell people this because
we already know it and you already know
it unless you're talking to
six-year-old oh and here we go this is
she continues doesn't hurt that on Geo
TV on Game of Thrones the other night
the stark sisters also said our story
isn't over yeah oh really yeah oh it
doesn't hurt oh no [ __ ]
no why cuz no matter what happens on a
TV show
it doesn't hurt on a fictional TV show
oh hey doesn't hurt imagine hanging out
with it hey doesn't hurt that on Game of
Thrones the other night the stark
sisters also said our story isn't over
imagine if you were eating brunch with
that person and somebody said that I
would get up and go to the valet get my
car and as they were looking at me with
a confused face I just be looking back
at him every few seconds until my car
came then I'd get in the car and I'd
[Music]
our story isn't over [ __ ]
this is not how my story will end
[Music]
you probably think I'm the crazy one for
doing this for really you're the crazy
one for making me do this
the courts not over here we go so few
words that mean so much our story isn't
over so few words that mean so much
hey here's even fewer words that mean
more at [ __ ] yeah
you have the power this very moment to
reach for things and go after dreams you
thought you had to ignore oh my god so
let's let's put somebody in that
situation there I you know what I want
to be a basketball player but I have to
ignore that never mind
I have the power actually to reach for
that so that's I'm just putting it in a
technical sense there your story isn't
over and only you have the power to
write your story not if some guy with
[ __ ] money comes along and helps you
out though really so stop waiting and
stop being scared you got this
flexing bicep emoji y'all have a
beautifully written day angry now I told
you the quote now we all know that quote
is horrid it's horrid and it's poison
there's a song that nas has and Andy
says physician's prescription
prescriptions for medicine which is
poison and he says which is poison which
is s Akaka sale which is poison and that
quote is poison now if you say you know
if you wrote that quote and that's fine
stop waiting and stop being scared you
could say that which is poison but it's
okay
morning loves so much integral at the
past few months they could say that it's
fine
you said it which is poison but it's
fine so anyway this is the picture
attached with the horrid and harrowing
quote recaptured and I and and okay so
this lady is on a bed facedown now I'm
gonna give you a guess is she but [ __ ]
naked or not now you guessed right
because you are a baby and you know this
podcast and you're and you're in my cult
and you would know that if somebody
posted a quote like that by now because
of the previous episodes we are learning
how people are and if you post something
like that now I am your elder if you
post something like that and you're a
true baby you know that if somebody
posts a picture and a caption like that
the picture attached to it will either
be of an annoying as [ __ ] couple in the
sunset or a woman
that's buck [ __ ] naked [ __ ] naked
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] naked
that's a Papoose song now Shabat naked
Shabbat nake Shabbat nake now I would
tell her to turn round but she already
turn round you can see her [ __ ] naked
ass sexually sexually forthcoming and
she's naked
shot is directly behind her which means
if she spread or ass cheeks a little
more you can see both holes so trout
Sutro Sh you grown woman yeah an
Instagram talking about in her growth
let's not see Yin or holes if you talk
about inner hole inner growth let's not
also see inside you dude if she spread
her ass cheeks an inch you could see a
bits and pieces if she spread her ass
cheeks you can see little discoloration
[Laughter]
if she put her right hand and a right
cheek and her left hand and a left cheek
and moved them away from each other you
could see her fried butterfly [ __ ] man
hey guess what your story's over okay
you story ended you know what it ended
with little discoloration hey man
nobody's [ __ ] taking you seriously
how about this don't show your [ __ ]
and your [ __ ] and try to be Gandhi
Dylan then-then-then
[Music]
hi I'm Krista Lea from NBC's canceled
undateable don't show your [ __ ] and
[ __ ] if you're trying to be mother
Teresa de Ling ding ding ding hey i'm
chris d'elia from nbc's cancelled
whitney but here's the bottom line don't
show what's a pink between your legs if
you're trying to be Elon Musk bling ding
ding ding
hey what's up it's Chris D'Elia from
TBS's glory days eight years ago do you
think do you think Steve Jobs ever
showed us his balls no then you don't
Delinda and god damn what's wrong with
this [ __ ] conch that might be the
problem is that it's a freak conch yeah
we all [ __ ] live in a free country
conch you can show you bits and pieces
now I'm not [ __ ] saying don't show
you bits and pieces but if you're gonna
show you bits and pieces don't talk
about inner growth or how stories end
cuz your story's over
you're gonna be labeled slaw
I'm so [ __ ] hot and it's so [ __ ]
slammin ass [ __ ] sweaty I put on one
of my good shirts I like my shirt it's a
t-shirt it's not [ __ ] that crazy
alright let's just check these [ __ ]
hashtags before we get the [ __ ] out of
here oh boy my producer set it up
alright and I [ __ ] clicked out of it
alright here we go
Neil oh wow all right Neil I think we've
talked to you before I don't remember
but dude you've got the number one
change of all time Neil his handle is at
taking you to pound town tak n you two
like the band and then pound town hey
man you frat guy what's your take on
those guys girls that plaster their
Instagram handle on their car window
Sidhu she I don't even take issue with
that I mean that's ridiculous but the
fact that taking you to pound
countess callin anything do she is crazy
go to the one about the [ __ ] one I
pointed to earlier and don't have it one
forum one fire there we go
Holly mounts your pornstar at Holly
mounts great good job love it when the
handle is the [ __ ] same thing is the
thing the name at Crystal Leah what do
you think about white people who say
ninja cuz they want to say the n-word so
bad but can't do it if if anyone ever
said you know what I'm saying my ninja
in front of me I would go like this like
actually I go like this
oh that's what I would do that'd be my
reaction dude what's up my ninja what's
up my need you last guy I heard said
that was a black guy just don't say that
you're white you're black Asian Indian
doesn't matter you're green don't say it
what if you were a ninja in real life
are there ninjas in real life yeah
somewhere right well if you were a ninja
in LA an actual ninja like trained and
you're like a ninja but you dressed
regular but you were a [ __ ] ninja how
did you become a ninja you got to go to
like the Ninja Academy oh god I don't
know you probably you know what you have
to have a lot of honestly if you're a
ninja inner growth you really do you
have to have a lot of inner growth which
means you never showed anybody you fried
butterfly or you [ __ ] hairy balls
um ninja dude how about how stupid that
is what's that ninja oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm gonna do one more do your
listen to the podcast would you would
that make them true babies or immediate
elders this guy wrote gaining the system
like a [ __ ] it's gaming the system
you [ __ ] dick Caleb will at Caleb
will underscore I am take the last part
off my parent my dad listens to every
episode which is weird because I
definitely mentioned fried butterfly so
he's gonna hear that
sar dad my mom I'm pretty sure doesn't
hope she doesn't because if she does
sure didn't say bits and pieces they are
they made me so I guess they are the
technical elders but uh I don't know man
you've still got to put out the elders
people would be coming up me like I'm
working towards elders it's Oh some guy
came up to me at the Utah shows the
other day and very creepily said and I
know he was trying to be humorous but he
looked at me after he took a picture
with me walked away and said hey man for
real
he said I'm prepared to kill to become
an elder hey ma'am that's creepy don't
know you don't say don't know you don't
say but bro also secretly
don't tell anybody but thank you dude
I'm gonna wrap this up man this was a
fun episode really fun remember to check
out movement watches get 15% off with
free shipping and free returns
MVM t-dot-com / Congrats square cash
have you switched to square cash yet for
the cat the cash app download the free
square cash app for iOS or Android now I
got dates coming up I got Phoenix
Arizona Tempe Arizona New Brunswick New
Jersey Boone honor that's ecology Puma :
Charlotte North Charlotte North Carolina
Adelaide Australia Perth Melbourne
Sydney Brisbane Australia Columbus Ohio
Irvine California Irvine California and
San Jose California that's what we're
doing babies why don't you come by where
you're [ __ ] uqdah merch merchandise
announcements get made on Twitter so be
sure to follow there we got restocked
CUDA shirts restocked congratulations
shirts restocked all sorts of [ __ ]
you can also get the stand-up stuff
there - man on fire go watch it and tell
people to watch it if you want to be in
my cult you got to share this you got to
share man on fire you got to share the
congratulations episode if if the
[ __ ] [ __ ] takes a dip now I'll focus
on stand-up and threatening you
rate and review this episode this
podcast please congratulations pod
hashtag congratulations pod thank you
you guys are great go to Crystal Viacom
or congratulations congratulations pod
com Twitter's Congrats pod and acting
hashtag congratulations prime now guys
thanks for listening and remember if you
want to show you bits and pieces fines
but don't act like Gandhi
[Music]